thank you for joining us Solomon is with
us in Atlanta hi Solomon welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve
what's up well Dave long story short I'm
a doctor
graduated from the Medical School just
finished residency and I have about
380,000 in student loans mainly all from
out of the cold school good loudmouth
blinding I was planning to do the public
service loan forgiveness program no to
pay it off however that didn't kind of
fall through with my current employment
so I'm trying to figure out the good way
to to pay this off and do so comfortably
in depth and to become debt free of this
financial burden okay just for future
reference 30,000 people have now applied
for the loan serve the federal loan
service forgiveness bublik service
forgiveness 96 have been granted it out
of 30 out of 30 thousand it's a complete
scam it's not happening
the government has screwed you're so
good I'm glad you're not signed up for
that so what is your income please God
tell me it's large
it's my combined I'm married so with my
wife it's about three hundred and thirty
good okay so you're gonna you don't get
to live like a doctor because you're a
broke doctor yeah you're gonna live like
a college student
okay I hope you had to start buying crap
can't answer that
have you started buying crap but bought
one thing this one what the car would
you buy the car I got yeah yeah now Dee
yeah what'd you pay for it about fifty
thousand okay you're three hundred
eighty thousand dollars in debt you can
never do that again I don't plan to you
can never do
anything like that again you're not
going on vacation you're not buying a
house you are a broke doctor here's the
thing you have this absolutely fabulous
income and you are going to destroy your
wealth building ability with that income
if you don't clear this debt up and
treat it like it's cancer and we're
going to hit it with chemo and
everything we've got and so I am NOT a
band-aid off slowly guy that crap does
not work and so what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes is I would live on
$50,000 a year or less which would make
me debt-free in under three years okay
and then I would start my life the great
news is you have the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater outcome we know
that because you've gone to school your
whole freakin life mm-hmm and you're
very smart academically or you wouldn't
be where you are okay you have the
ability to delay pleasure which is a
sign of emotional maturity and you have
a great intellect let's use those two
things and apply them to this mess that
you are in called deeply in debt now you
can do it the other way but I'll tell
you this your colleagues are walking
around out there with three hundred four
hundred two hundred thousand dollars
worth of medical school debt for a
decade because they play with it and
they never kill the disease the only way
you kill it is extreme treatment radical
and it's the only way it goes away it's
gonna stay with you forever otherwise so
that's what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes I would treat it like I am a
broke doctor because I'm a broke doctor
and broke doctors don't buy $50,000 cars
or going 50 thousand other vacations so
you're not doing that crap anymore you
get on a tight budget beans and rice
rice and beans and clean up this mess
because if you take the three year old
older than you are now you and go
forward with a three or four hundred
thousand dollar income and no debt
you're gonna be so wealthy it's going to
be blinding if you watch what you're
doing but if you
just screw around with this thing and
keep it like it's a pet it's gonna be a
problem for you